bonsoir
jean airoldi le réal ménard qu'on
connaît bien mike parenté et nadine
gelly qui sera président du comité
exécutif si évidemment il est élu il
forme le la mairie la dissension que
j'ai pensé quoi de ses nouvelles recrues
ces quatre belles prises pour l'équipe
de monsieur coderre aujourd'hui
connaissant bien à monsieur ménard
évidemment c'est un érudit de tout ce
qui se passe au niveau municipal au
niveau politique donc aucun problème les
trois ans et des personnes qui sont qui
ne connaissent pas la politique mais qui
ont les capacités de pouvoir gérer donc
on l'a vu avec nadine gelly ont levé
avec un mike parenté et avec aussi
monsieur et relie donc chacun pourra
contribuer par leurs connaissances à
faire avancer les choses donc pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est une belle prise pour
l'équipe total luc ferrandez il grossit
l'équipe plat
sentiment partagé belle prise réal
ménard un homme que j'apprécie beaucoup
j'espère qu'on va le mettre dans un
poste qui exige beaucoup de minutie puis
peu de créativité parce que moi j'ai
pris sa suite au grand parc et puis j'ai
trouvé que on avait gaspillé son talent
c'est un gars qui est en mettant au
grand parc senghor qui est très très
très minutieux qui lie tous qui est
aussi un un facilitateur avec les gens
qui l'entourent excellent mike parenté
god la rue goût du commerce go agréable
avec pouvoir faire beaucoup pour la
ville de montréal les deux autres on
sait pas quoi dire je suis surpris
d'avoir qui va mettre une parfaite
néophytes présidente exécutive ça
j'arrive pas à comprendre
jeudi s'est jusqu'ici pas ce que vous en
aviez déjà parlé luc cette capacité
d'être allé chercher quand même pas mal
de monde et qu'est ce que ça nous dit
sur chaque campagne par rapport à celle
de madame plantes mais monsieur kader
c'est c'est une personne extrêmement
chaleureuse où au point de vue personnel
de au plan personnel il lorsqu'il a
décidé qu'elle ait travaillé avec toi il
devient ton ami automatiquement ça ça
dure c'est une phrase amis c'est une
france qui mesure 2 après c'est ton
frère s'il se présente comme étant bon
et appelle mon frère si le dire ce gars
là même moi quand j'étais dans
l'opposition je boxe quand ils sortent
mais non mais j'arrivais pas trop à le
détester canton le terrain à côté de
l'autre parce que ses parents aient
assez loin pour être enfin grâce et ça
j'ai passé moins de deux heures chien se
met mais c'est seul sait personne à
personne il va chercher des gens et les
amène etc c'est la suite de problèmes
alors est ce qui est capable de créer
une équipe avec tous ces gens là ce qui
va rester présent auprès de ces gens là
est ce qu'il va faire son rôle de
coaching est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas tout
simplement les faire disparaître
derrière lui comme il le fait dans le
premier mode et il les informe et
seulement après avoir informé les médias
comme ça arrive souvent là c'est leur
produit lors du hockey à nice tension
une des craintes
que monsieur coderre donnait l'image
d'un one man show là d'un en tout cas
dans cette période de cette campagne qui
est jeune il donne l'impression qui est
capable de s'entourer bas et c'est comme
ça chaque campagne électorale évidemment
la saison fait patte blanche parce qu'on
va avoir des amis autour de nous il ya
besoin de 103 candidats c'était un gars
qui a extrêmement convaincant ce sens il
faut on peut pas le nier la place qu'il
veut quelque chose qui va le chercher le
reste ça va être la suite c'est là
qu'ils nous montrent à six a
véritablement changé lui à partie
valérie plantes on va regarder la fiche
qui mise
la dernière fois c'était l'homme de la
situation n'avait voulu provoquer un
clin d'oeil et là la fiche que vous
voyez elle mis sur son sourire une dita
qui a parlé de mon sourire
je vais faire du judo avec ça qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
initiation ça m'a fait sourire quand je
les ai vus mais je suis pas sûr que les
commerçants sur les rues sainte
catherine sur les rues saint denis sur
les grandes artères ont le sourire
facile comme elle je pense que c'est un
peu à un regard de faire une publicité
comme celle là faut dire qu'apple a fera
beaucoup mais est-ce que ça va se
réaliser c'est autre chose encore une
fois c'est des belles paroles d'un beau
sourire c'est sympathique quelqu'un qui
reste pas montréal un touriste qui voit
sa volée roire c'est le fun a le sourire
et a fait des choses mais quelqu'un qui
vit à montréal un commerçant qui
peut-être pendant la pandémie fermer son
commerce a eu de la difficulté ou tout
ça j'aimerais bien les entendre sur
cette publicité l'udc mais je pense à
lui aussi voulu se mettre en opposition
avec denis coderre on se rappelle lors
de la dernière campagne électorale denis
coderre n'avait pas pu sourire de la
campagne c'était un homme stressé c'est
un homme amer et elle a voulu faire
valoir ce contraste là je pense aussi
que l a voulu séparer du rire combien de
fois dans les médias sociaux et même
chez certains utilisateurs
éditorialistes on s'est moqué de valérie
plantes en dix ans elle nourrit en
pleine face parce que c'est une femme
qui rit facilement elle nourrit en
pleine face elle rit de nous et séverine
nos problèmes là elle a voulu peut-être
un peu amenuisé le côté
rires aux éclats maintenant moi je
trouve pas non plus que c'est une bonne
idée parce que ça centre la campagne sur
elle et j'aimerais tellement que ça soit
toute l'équipe alors je trouve que c'est
un peu malheureux il ya eu un débat on a
eu un reportage vendredi qu'on a diffusé
sur la hauteur des gratte-ciel monsieur
coderre veut
permettre désormais que les gratte-ciel
dépasse le mont royal une vieille règle
qui existe il est donc deux camps madame
plans dits non monsieur coderre dit ben
il faut regarder ça qu'est ce que
j'avais qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa
naissance on mais je rappelle que cette
cette mesure-là été mis en place à 92
avec le premier plan d'urbanisme de la
ville de montréal 6 à la mi été mis là
c'est qu'il y avait une raison montréal
se distingue par ses montants que je
comprends qu'on veut densifier davantage
parce qu'on veut garder les gens veulent
qu'on veut pas que les gens s'en moquent
à l'extérieur de montréal mais il ya
aussi une limite à vouloir aller plus
loin moi je pense que c'est un sou
discussion où monsieur coderre audi qui
consulteraient les citoyens et qui
prendrait acte de ce que les citoyens
vont dire pour prendre sa décision
donc j'aimerais bien voir comment va se
faire cette consultation publique et
j'aimerais bien voir si on va écouter
les citoyens jusqu'à la fin parce que
c'est un sujet très sensible pour les
moriani luc ferrandez c'est pas juste
une question de hauteur
quand tu fais des immeubles en hauteur
c'est béton air climatisé ascenseur donc
ce triptyque de dépenses qui fait que tu
peux pas arriver à moins de 700 pieds
700 $ le pied carré au moment de la
vente mais à 700 $ le pied carré qui
achètent ça donc c'est pas vrai que
lorsque tu construit en hauteur tu règle
le problème des familles tu crées juste
plus d'ailleurs toronto or beaucoup plus
d'immeubles en hauteur que nous et
beaucoup plus de problèmes
d'accessibilité et la banlieue de
toronto ça grandit sans cesse à ajax
vous avez traduit dans la ville d'ajax
c'est une congestion permanente à 40 km
de la ville alors que la plainte oran
ville
alors ce n'est pas un triptyque que je
remercie mon dieu qui prend sa place je
vous en remercie anie samson luc
ferrandez à très bientôt à bientôt
invités au revoir